hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
oh jesus it's monday again what am i
doing with my life
july 25th 2022
are you feeling that right now are you
on your way to work going why what would
happen
if i just kept driving
you know
wouldn't it be great if you just [ __ ]
were driving by the building right as
your superior
your boss
your manager
the douche who you have to listen to was
standing out there and you just sort of
look at them as you drive by and they're
looking at you
like why are you going by the entrance
and you just kind of look at them and
just
just shake your head now like not today
buddy
not today not today sweetheart
just put the window down listen
not feeling it today
well i'll tell you why
i can tell you exactly why let me pull
up
you have owned every monday of my
[ __ ] life
of my life
call back to the pirate
for the last [ __ ] six years okay let
me tell you something sugar tits mel
gibson reference
this monday is mine
this is my monday
that's another thing that you know you
could just win political office
and if elected
i would say
that once a month you are allowed to say
to your manager that this is my monday
why is this so [ __ ] loud it just
seems like it's it's it's everything was
fine
hey
most people do the levels before they do
a podcast i don't know what happened all
of a sudden it got a little loud over
here
um must be a goddamn varmint in this
[ __ ] [ __ ] hole
uh
all right so you guys know if you've
been listening to this podcast for a
while you know that me
okay mr [ __ ] phony hollywood
grew up on the east coast right dude
everybody out there was too [ __ ] real
for him so he [ __ ] hopped in his
[ __ ] car
drove across the country out to [ __ ]
la la land where their [ __ ] bunch of
pedophiles [ __ ] each other in a hot
tub
right
that's what goes on out there
um you would think that i am just a a
lost cause but you know i always keep
coming back
to my inner redneck you know what i mean
i do like uh
i like drugs and um i've been actually
wanting to uh you know
my wife won't let me get a gun right
so as far as she knows there's no gun in
the house you don't want to say hey well
she don't know won't hurt it well maybe
it will
um i actually saw these things for all
you uh uh uh uh gun gun people out there
all right i got a question for you
what do you think about these i took a
picture there was a sign i was going for
a ride in my old truck today and i saw a
sign
that said non-lethal projection
no background checks no permits required
interstate travel friendly
so my question is what does it do
you know house okay it's non-lethal
which means this then that would mean
there's no way for me to kill you with
this thing
so what exactly does it do
does it shoot a giant net out like
[ __ ]
a villain on the batman series like what
comes out the end of it what do you
think about it my big thing
because i don't mind killing somebody
that comes into my house i don't have a
problem with that you know what i mean
unless it gets on the rook then it's
like ah jesus i gotta [ __ ] cut that
section out
uh no it's um
you know my thing is my [ __ ] ears you
know what i mean my ears already ring i
don't need to be you know
blowing somebody away and then my ears
are ringing even louder
uh
that would annoy the [ __ ] out of me so
i'm wanting with these non-lethal ones
or can't you put like rock salt into
your [ __ ] uh
shotgun like what do they shoot at white
people in portland oregon what are the
cops
[Music]
um i don't want the ammunition that they
shoot at non-white people i want the
ammunition that they shoot at white
people because you know not because i
don't want to kill somebody that would
you know if anybody ever came in my
house it's it's just i just don't
want that loud bang and then my ears
ring even [ __ ] louder although i've
been reading up on tinnitus or tetanus
however the [ __ ] you're supposed to say
it
um
and these people are you know it's just
all of this [ __ ]
that claims that they can cure it which
obviously they can't so i always get the
name of the product and then you try to
look up a review and these people are
such pieces of [ __ ] that they actually
have they've actually created phony
reviews that pop up first
hoping that you're going to read that
like i talked to a guy recently you know
i told you i'm getting rid of some stuff
selling some guitars i got my suits that
i wore on letterman and there's this guy
who has a comedy like museum
i'm going to donate though then
to him
and i was talking to him and he was
he said was talking all of this crazy
stuff he was saying how
you know there's a there's a medicine
they give you
um
i got to be careful here because well
it's the internet nothing has to be
right right just look into this [ __ ] if
they if you get prescribed valtrex
he was saying on an uh
an alarming
amount of people i thought you know it
wasn't like point zero zero zero percent
it was like a actual percentage
like you know like fifteen percent or
seven percent
it does
like irreparable damage to your kidneys
so people take that if they if they get
like herpes or cold sores or like uh if
they they're older and they had shingles
and i guess the information according to
this guy was on the fda website but they
buried it
because from what i've heard the fda was
infiltrated from people that used to
work in the pharmaceutical industry
which they never should have even
allowed to have those [ __ ]
psychopaths on there but nobody gives a
[ __ ]
right
and he was also telling me that vitamin
c is uh is really bad for your kidneys
too and you have to watch out for the
amount and he was claiming that the
amount of vitamin c in an emergency
which i take when i'm going on the
[ __ ] road he said what's in that
packet is too much now i don't know and
i don't know where to rese like how do
you find out
what the right information is and can
somebody
anonymously who works in the
pharmaceutical company uh uh industry
right in just how do you do that for a
[ __ ] living
like how do you just sit there
and come out with some [ __ ] that you
know has some crazy side effects for a
certain portion of people and then
[ __ ]
do everything you can to hide that
[ __ ] information actually create
phony [ __ ] reports it's crazy
i sound like an andy vaxxer right now
don't i you gotta pick your battles man
you got to pick your battles uh
who knows i went i went with the vaccine
because they first tried it out in
england which is a bunch of white people
so i figured all right it's got to work
on some level
because generally speaking white people
will sue the [ __ ] out of you you know
because of their status
you know
do you think the right you think the the
royal family can even get covered if
you're like totally like inbred or
whatever
i mean i think what that [ __ ]
red-headed kid did in the royal family
was it was needed
genetically
i mean they were disappearing up their
own royal freckled [ __ ] like i mean
just how many more like
you know i'm not gonna lie i would say
uh the older fella there the blonde one
was a good looking dude but a lot of
them woof
jesus
jesus
you know
what because they're a royal family they
should
they should be beautiful well yeah
all the hollywood movies you know all of
those ones there's always like beautiful
people
you know in all of those lord of the
rings there's always some
porcelain-skinned
[ __ ] fragile woman in distress is
there or now do they make them all like
you know
now all the women are like bad ass
where they just treated women like such
[ __ ] and made them such weak characters
for all these years that they didn't
then they just did like a 180
and rather than writing a strong female
character up against a strong male
character blood they just they just
flipped it's like all right now the
woman's strong the guy's a [ __ ] and
then all of a sudden there was like all
these these
these [ __ ] action movies well i don't
mind if the woman's a superhero when
she's doing that but when you see like
just like it's a regular [ __ ] movie
and she's not a superhero and she's
throwing some guy upside down through a
[ __ ] playglass window it's like all
right the guy wasn't even running at you
you had no momentum i'm to believe i
mean maybe you're crossfitting
you know
maybe that's why those people that
crossfit run down the street with the
[ __ ] holding an office chair above
their head
that has been the greatest thing about
covid watching the crossfit
horseshit go away
god how annoying was that
[ __ ] sitting outside trying to eat
something these people remind you that
you have to be working out and they have
to show you that you it's like dude i
work out too all right i do it in the
gym with other people working out i
don't even running by other people
trying to enjoy that [ __ ] breakfast
get me over here questioning my toast
you can't i should have got the salad
instead of potatoes
sorry um
anyway so you wouldn't know it but i'm
actually in a good mood
i had a good day my life's starting to
slow down
uh
we're turning in the movie this week to
miramax
which is sort of the final deal and then
we start adding music and we
colorize it you know
we uh make my charlie brown head a
little more uh
visibly enticing
for a a family valued audience whatever
the [ __ ] it is we're gonna we'll make
we're gonna somehow make me look
palatable
um
so today is like my only day off
you know and i went
uh you know i went to the playground
with my kids
had a great time and uh
although my son had like a meltdown i
think he was a little over tired
[ __ ] kid goes hard man
he just [ __ ] goes hard he like banged
his head like three times
like he banged it once and then he
[ __ ] a little about a
half hour later he like hit it twice
and then he just started doing that cry
where i know he needs a nap
and he just
he just becomes another person
you know when you care i don't know if
you got a two-year-old but or if you
have your kids are older but you
remember when they start doing that
thing where they're just doing that cry
and they're just leaning back and
they're doing everything you can
everything they can to make you drop
them on the pavement
so you got to hold them you know
you know you got to hold them like tiki
barber did after he [ __ ] was known
for fumbling the way you would hold the
football after that you got to like hold
your son like that as you bring him to
the [ __ ] car
um
but we were having uh a great time my
son is so funny he's like super friendly
and he calls kids his age babies
he just walks up to him and he puts his
face like right near their face you know
they have like no boundaries he's just
like hi baby
then he goes flying down the slide he's
absolutely uh
fearless and uh my daughter's like this
amazing you know my son did something
the other day and i just started
cracking up
he was just being funny just did
something crazy
and my daughter my daughter just looks
at me she goes hey
she goes don't laugh at my little
brother
i might have told you that story i was
so proud of her like that's right you
stick up for
you stick up for it all right dad needs
a timeout here
um
yeah so i had a good day with that you
know went out got a little [ __ ] my
found a new espresso place where they
they don't burn the beans
[ __ ] sucked though i showed up all
the tables there was one table left like
right in the sun
so i had to sit down you know there was
this big
four top table that this this you know
this couple took so i'm like well you
should have taken the two top
you know you took the four because you
went for the shade
and i was like should i go for the
shades i said [ __ ] it i was like you
guys mind if i sit here and they lied
and they said no and then they were
bitching about something and i noticed
that they were like sort of whisper
talking then i kind of felt bad that i
made him talk that way so i kind of
sucked down the coffee
and got the [ __ ] out of there um anyway
let's get back to what i really want to
talk about are my red sox ever going to
win again
we have not won a game since we won
back-to-back games
against the yankees
like weeks ago there was the all-star
break thank god but jesus christ so now
today i believe we're like 47 and 47 or
48 and 48. we're slipping back down
beneath 500 and everybody's sitting
there [ __ ] on him
and it's like dude
everybody's [ __ ] hurt
sale is out avaldy's out walk is out
nick pavetta's been in and out of the
lineup
devers is hurt
kiki hernandez is [ __ ] out you know
what i mean
ah jeez i listen all this [ __ ] from
yankee my friends who are yankee fans
the worst is a buddy of mine he calls me
you guys what's going on i saw that
score he acted like he was concerned
i was teasing about it um
but it's like what's going on is we have
the worcester red sox pitching against
the blue it was still bad
it was still bad why the [ __ ]
i mean there's just been a lot of
looking up and you can't find the fly
ball
and you do that hands out like i don't
know where it is
we got some baby face kid i don't even
know half the red so i've been watching
them all year we have so many people out
i don't even know half their names this
babyface kid they move around in the
[ __ ] outfield he had no idea where
the ball was so he's slowly walking in
trying to find it
and the thing ends up landing like
way out by the warning track
and that dude on toronto has the white
dreads
uh he's not a white guy with dreads he's
a he's a i don't know what he is latino
black and he has like white dreads like
uh like dreadlocks that are white in
case you don't understand what i'm
saying
um
he got an inside the park grand slam
but you know what's funny
losing 28 to five still only counts as
one loss so i was like all right well
maybe we'll win the next day
we didn't
i'm like all right maybe we'll win today
as far as i know we didn't
i ended up going out after the eighth
inning we were sort of chipping away and
i think was like eight to three or eight
to four
let's see what the old red sox did here
see what the old red sox did i was all
petty tweeting during that
eight to four
lost again so what are we now what do we
know huh
isn't it amazing how you can't get your
[ __ ] cell phone to do anything and
then anytime you accidentally [ __ ]
touch it the [ __ ] thing just goes
like i don't know what it does it's like
what did i even just do there
48 and 48
five game behind the [ __ ] blue jays
uh we shall see yankees haven't been
doing well lately though we'll see i
think they peaked a little early
you know
just [ __ ] with you this is just i'm
just gonna be this grumpy
[ __ ] baseball fan for the rest of the
uh the season but um
i'm still gonna watch okay because
that's what being a fan is
uh
hey i'm reading a great book right now
uh
one of my favorite comedians and people
and just
one of the coolest people to hang out
with just absolutely hilarious uh
marilyn rice cub wrote a book uh famous
and uh
i mean
i just been tearing through this but i
mean a lot of times you know people send
you books you don't and i just knew
she's like she's she's funny and she's
unique i bet this is gonna be [ __ ]
good and i picked it up and
like i can't put the thing down
uh
if she just has all of these hilarious
stories about just being shut down
emotionally and getting involved in
relationships professionally and
personally that just are not working for
her
and it's just
i don't want to ruin the book but it's
absolutely like
it's [ __ ] hilarious it's a great book
if you get a chance it just came out i'm
giving it a shout out here on the
podcast all right oprah winfrey has a
book club so do i i recommend wilmington
wilmington's lie
the insurrection of 1892 and the rise of
white supremacy and maryland rice cub
famous
i'm all over the road here
that's how i like to read you know
a little horrifying history
and a uh relatable honest autobiography
of stories
you got to read the harrison 4 chapter
2.
that's a highlight
another highlight she moves into a house
she can't afford with some psycho who's
not paying rent
uh her being a waitress
at denny's
working her way up from bussing tables
and actually making the ranch dressing
which one of the great visuals a giant
tub and she has i just was picturing it
like an ore from a rowboat
like just
i don't know anyway um
old freckles has been doing a lot of
stand up and i got to tell you something
now that i'm kind of getting my free
time back
and uh i can kind of chill
and actually use my brain for other [ __ ]
the new stuff has just been pouring out
of me
and i've had more goddamn fun going down
to the comedy store
you know uh
went down there last night popped in and
it was just all this new [ __ ] and then
it was like leading to the stuff that
already have worked out but i'm going
into it a different way
it's gonna be awesome and uh i'm gonna
[ __ ] murder this weekend in montreal
i know i am i can't wait and i'm doing
i'm gonna be doing sets all around la
getting ready for this thing because uh
i'm going to the home
of the hated habs as a bruins fans but i
gotta you gotta respect that all right
well they got 24 cups
won the first seven on a pond
in the early 1900's but whatever you
know
um
we'll give him that i'll give him at
least 17.
kidding
uh i'm very excited about that and uh i
also talked to my agent
because oh you got an agent bill oh are
you in show business i usually say
booker so i can come off as being
falsely humble
i talked to my booking agent and i have
four more professional franchises that i
need to see a home game of and then i've
seen them all
i've seen them all
i need the ottawa senators the carolina
hurricanes and then the two newest
franchises in the nhl i got to see the
vegas knights
and i got to see the seattle cragging
seattle crack it
my wife's always wanted to go to seattle
not to a hockey game but that could be
my part of the vacation so maybe i'll
take her up there
um
and i'll check out a game with her or
something like that because i just did a
gig just outside of uh
seattle maybe i'll do one night at the
more who knows
who knows i mean that the the
possibilities are endless
um
yeah very excited about that uh
you know i looked at my my daughter's
vacations when she has time off
i i got the app now i always had the app
i didn't know how to use it so i've
blocked all of that out so i'm going to
be home for her vacations
i'm all set
i'm having fun now
that's what i'm doing there's an f-100
thing in [ __ ] tennessee that i've
always wanted to go to i'm [ __ ] doing
that [ __ ]
and i'm gonna continue to fight my urge
to buy a house in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere and sit on the back porch stare
into the tree line and slowly drink
myself to death
i'm not gonna do that but like when i
get overly tired and i work too much
like that's what plays
in my head
and for some reason i'm just all by
myself it's not like i move my whole
family out there i am just by myself
drinking a bottle of bourbon
until i die i don't know it's just like
uh
i'm one of those all or nothing
i got i got that i got that because i i
got to learn how to like
take you know
some i gotta [ __ ] express it
i need to take time off sometimes there
we go
that's what i was talking about when i
started all the callbacks which i was
talking about when i started this
[ __ ] podcast every once in a while
you know if i was running a business
just every once in a while i do run a
business and i don't do this but you
should do every once more just give
somebody a [ __ ] monday off
can you just get him off the goddamn
wheel
you know
it won't be great no tv no computer none
of that [ __ ]
you actually have time to look at
yourself and figure out what the [ __ ] is
going on with you
and why you're doing 80 of the [ __ ] that
you're doing because at least 60 of it
you don't want there was a lot of
numbers in there with no research behind
it but i think it was pretty accurate
um so anyway um yeah i'm gonna do stand
up like three nights this week
i'm knocking out this new [ __ ] i have
all of this these [ __ ] new ideas that
are coming to me uh
and i can just feel it
the things just yeah i'm gonna ride this
wave i'm gonna crush it fenway and once
i get through fenway
you know
then i'm on the other side of that the
movie will be done
it all opens up
just in time for football season
and for me to gamble away my kids future
i mean that's the game plan right
um
i know we shall see we'll see we'll see
what happens here
over the
uh the next month
you know they're talking about [ __ ]
rolling blackouts out here and all of
this [ __ ] i love how the rest of the
country kind of looks at the southwest
here going jesus those guys are [ __ ]
like what we're dealing with isn't
eventually coming your way
at least we're going to get it over with
i just view it as i remember
back in the day
when my mom was giving out the beating
she would line up me and all of my
siblings and i used to always be jealous
of the first two going [ __ ] it's at
least it's over they got it over quick
you're just standing there like oh god
maybe she'll be tired but she wasn't she
had stamina
my mom could eat up some innings
um
so we'll get it over soon get it over
with soon uh all right with that
apocalyptic
thing here am i going to really just
jump into the uh to the reads this fast
i have no idea i actually i got another
book that i'm going to read too i'm
slowly reading
the rest of the history of this country
which is fascinating to me like i want
to know
this is so weird i want to know when the
democratic party in the republican party
switched and how they did that
like how the democratic party was
conservative
so all the conservatives were democrat
and all the liberals were republican
which always cracks me up when they go
through history and you like
like some [ __ ] who's a conservative
actually that was the democratic party
you did that it's like yeah but if you
live back then you would have been
democratic
you have been a democrat it's just
i don't know
there's so many people that are alive
because simply because of modern
medicine
you know oh that's an interesting thing
anybody listening uh
from a country i don't i don't know how
to put this without getting in trouble
a country that's being oppressed
by our country how about that
okay do morons survive do
mouth-breathing morons survive
because i've always had this fantasy
that you know if we weren't like [ __ ]
if we didn't have the lifestyle that
we'd have there's like so many people
you know
let's start with wine and ass liberals
where everything hurts their [ __ ]
feelings like how the [ __ ]
would they get through a winter if they
lived in an impoverished country
you know they would make it
like is there less whining i don't want
to pick out a country because somebody
will sniff this out and try to make me
look like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
um like the douchebag conservatives
who are taking my abortion bit i [ __ ]
love it like they take the bushmen and
all they take is the part that agrees i
trashed both sides they just take the
part that agrees with them and this
woman wrote like there's a lot of uh
pro-choice people
watching this part crying right now and
she had like the emoji like crying
laughing which i just thought was such
an odd response to that like if you
really
are trying to protect
uh babies from not getting killed that
you would
just i don't know it's just like so this
topic is funny to you so it's just like
uh it's more about
you just wanted to win you don't give a
[ __ ] about the babies you just wanted to
be right
i actually feel bad for a lot of right
right to life people that they think
it's they actually think it's a
religious issue
[Laughter]
it isn't
it's not i mean i know you could say
thou shall not kill could be religious
for you but that's not the reason why
they're doing it as far as what i and
this is what i what i've read is was it
is what i believe i believe it's a
racial issue i believe that you know
because most of more abortions than not
are done by white people they want to
keep those white babies alive
so that they can vote for a white
candidate that's what i've read and i'm
like you know what that makes way more
[ __ ] sense to me
that makes way more sense to me
considering
the complete lack of respect we have for
babies in other countries
that are that are sitting on the goop
that we want
um it doesn't line up
or maybe that's the deal right isn't
that the old joke once the baby's alive
then you can [ __ ]
put in the electric chair or something
like that sorry i'm doing 80 stand up
now jesus christ bill what happened you
know what happened was my air
conditioner went off
i finally figured out that you know what
happened i accidentally unplugged it
i was like oh great my air conditioner
is up
do you like how when i was talking
earlier about weak people acting like
they wouldn't survive
like like i would survive
you know if i lived in an impoverished
country right
with my gingered skin
you know i would yeah i i can laugh
personally i wouldn't live in this
climate
like i would be one of the few homeless
people that actually would choose
minneapolis
like that's a good you know i'd scroll
my beard out
you know what i mean
i'd go in a hardware store i would steal
some like rope
and have the rope belt like i think one
of the biggest things if you want to
keep making
earning an income as a homeless person
is you got to be able to [ __ ]
hold your pants up
once people think they're going to see
homeless junk like they they're not as
giving
you know
but if you can just kind of like
you know
two things you got to have the rope belt
and you need to wash your hands in a
puddle of whatever liquid you can find
before you start begging sorry
um
i dropped some [ __ ] off at a homeless
encampment yesterday
i don't [ __ ] with the ones downtown the
ones downtown
that's like mad max [ __ ] okay
unless i got mel gibson riding [ __ ]
shotgun with me i'm not going down there
all right so i i stay
to the ones where it's just a strip
okay it's not like
like did we have homeless encampments in
downtown
l.a that are about a week away from
being
classified as a sovereign state that's
just
just existing
by their own set of rules and when you
go in there it's like it's you know yeah
they're free to feed on you
um or maybe that's just all my fear i
have no [ __ ] idea so um
i just you know i always try to
you know i don't bring my [ __ ] to
goodwill anymore [ __ ] those people
you know they throw most of this [ __ ] in
the ocean
i actually think that today you know i
was at the uh
the playground
and uh you know some [ __ ] [ __ ]
just there's literally a trash barrel
right there and they just leave all
their food [ __ ] on the ground drives me
up the [ __ ] wall
so i pick it up right because i'm the
i'm the martyr in this story right
and uh
i would love to hear other people's
podcasts who were driving in front of me
on the road in l.a and hear how they
described me
how many times i lean on the horn as i
[ __ ] make myself out to be the hero
in this episode anyways i [ __ ] throw
it out
i was just thinking that whole stupid
thing you put litter in its place like
it's still going to get thrown out it's
just going
into the woods
or into the ocean just by a professional
you know they have uniforms and put
litter in its place where the animals
live there we go
um all right with that let's let's read
um
all right simply safe everybody
um do a little advertising read here
today's episode of the monday morning
podcast
broadcast today's episode of the monday
morning podcast is brought to you by
simply safe
home security i believe
home home i believe home should be the
safest place on earth for every family
doesn't that just sound like something a
candidate you wouldn't vote for
would say
i believe home should be the safest
place on earth for every family wow
really going out on a limb aren't you
i believe that ice cream tastes
delicious
um that's why i use and recommend simply
safe
okay let me let me put this more in my
words what do i believe i believe that
on a fly ball the right the guy on
second shouldn't go [ __ ] halfway to
third because the cunt's not gonna drop
it
all right but you know you're taking
away your whole chance to [ __ ] tag up
i never understood that and in field in
infield in yeah why don't you stand
right in front of the [ __ ] bat
because there's a guy on third
give yourself like 0.2 seconds to see
what's coming at you
you know and that's why i use and
recommend simply safe not because of
that other [ __ ] uh simply safe is
advanced home security that puts you
your home and your family's safeties
first here's why i love it simply safe
offers comprehensive protection not only
against intruders and burglary
burglary but against its expensive homes
and hazards from flooding to fires you
know i believe
that when you go out to get a to get a
milkshake an oreo shake because you're
progressive and you believe that whites
and blacks should live together right
and when you suck it down and you get
that ice cream headache i believe that a
fat guy that would sit next to a furnace
should run out and put his hands on your
forehead and that is why that very now
we got that's why i recommend simply
safe
also because simply safe offers
comprehensive protection not only
against intruders and burglary but i
already said this [ __ ] with 24 7
professional monitoring
simply safe agents take action
the moment a threat is detected
dispatching police or first responders
aren't police first responders
in an emergency
even if you're not home actually the
person who calls the cops
is the first responder responding to
their own emergency
um and that is why
that is why i recommend simply simply
safe
simply safe uses proprietary video
verification
technology so that monitoring agents can
visually confirm that a threat
it what is that is that a lacrosse stick
can you turn on the video it's a [ __ ]
axe
we have confirmation
uh the threat in order to get higher
priority 911 dispatch they can see
exactly what's going on
you know
jesus christ is that person carrying a
golf bag on their back with a bunch of
shotguns
oh it's balloons it's from shut no it's
balloons it's balloons it's a surprise
party sorry
stand down
monitoring plans are affordable
affordably priced
at a dollar a day with no long-term
contract or hidden fees because feeling
safe at home
shouldn't break the bank you can
customize the perfect system for your
home in just a few minutes at simply
safe dot com slash bar
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com slash bur go today and claim a
free indoor security camera plus twenty
percent off with interactive monitoring
go to simplysafe.com
year
over year i think it should be year
after year
year over year sounds like some one of
those math formulas you had to
remember last week someone used the
phrase oh no this is something else i'm
sorry
this is this is
that's not even part of their copy this
is something that somebody else wrote in
i just didn't copy and paste correctly
because i'm an old [ __ ] 54 on a computer
it ain't gonna it's not gonna it's not
gonna be pretty
it will not be pretty you know one of
the questions you know a lot of
questions get asked on the internet and
one of the ones that i thought was the
best was when the [ __ ] chick
uh that was sort of the the maitre d of
epstein island went to jail
ah table of 14 for three
um
she goes to jail for 20 years and
somebody finally goes well what about
everybody on that [ __ ] you know list
are you going to investigate them and
some people went to that island like 20
[ __ ] times like what are we doing
here
you know which goes back to the fact
that you think that maybe the guy you
know didn't kill himself maybe he got
whacked
man but that's just the level of power
that you can't [ __ ] with like if you
have the the power to go to an island 20
times
to [ __ ] children
i mean
that i mean that's i don't even know
what what part of the universe you're in
you know i went to go to coffee today
and i had like
the first front third of my truck
was in the red zone i'm like i'm gonna
get a ticket but i don't want to park it
under the tree cuz i just got it washed
okay that's the level i'm at like that's
that's my version of going to epstein
island and getting away with it
uh pedophilia bill
you're really trying to [ __ ] ring a
joke out of that aren't you okay year
over year
last week someone used the phrase year
over year and you said they must mean
year after year
the phrasing was correct
it is a common way of putting it in
financial terms
or when counting or measuring so i was
right
as far as it seemed like a math problem
uh formula that i wouldn't know
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself all right
well thank you for writing in
and correcting us so year over now i
gotta look it up
oh this is good this is good i'm gonna
be on the the [ __ ] smart part of the
internet
the egghead part
dare i say
year
over
year meaning
comparing or based on comparing the same
time period in successive years
year-over-year growth year over year
increases slash declines the insurers
said it paid out 16
last
for catastrophe and storm claims on a
year-over-year basis in the fourth
quarter well i didn't need that example
we all know that insurance companies are
not in the business of paying people
they are in the business of collecting
fees
embezzling money
and having lavish parties on islands
owned by some [ __ ] jerk-off i'm sorry
all right uh plastic
um hey bill you were talking about
plastic waste last week yes i know i was
in way over my head did you know no i
didn't i don't know anything about it
that's another thing that i wanted to
read up on
i wanted to read up on on on plastic
i wanted to read up on uh yeah when the
republican and democratic party switched
like how the like their ideologies from
conservative
to liberal and vice versa like how the
[ __ ] that happened
um
i was hanging out with a friend of mine
he was like really into teddy roosevelt
and i knew one story about him that he
got shot in the [ __ ] chest while
giving a speech and the guy finished the
[ __ ] speech
i'm like you know
that's quite a character to read up on
um all right
plastic all right you were talking about
plastic waste last week did you know
ninety percent of all plastic can't be
recycled
no
why is that but a hundred percent of the
collected recycled plastic is profitable
it's an eighty billion dollar a year
industry and they have a worse batting
average
than the sox did against the chase last
week
wow
man there's just so many things that we
there's just so many things on the list
like yeah we got to do something about
that
the companies that produce plastic make
a combined 900 billion dollars a year
to reiterate last week's listener they
will never talk about this because it's
too much money yeah and they just pay
off the politicians [ __ ] in politicians
they don't make any money
like influencers on instagram make more
money a year than the president of the
united states they're just they're set
up to be bribed
regardless of what color tie they have
on
uh to reiterate last week's listener
they will never talk about this because
it's too much money and most of the
renewable energy technology have a
lifespan of less than five years i.e
solar and require more oil to produce
than they would have burned red rocks
was awesome love to you and the family
back east um all right so then the
solution
is we need to have a lot less people
quickly
jesus christ where's joseph stalin when
you need him
man i got to tell you you know
that's going to be a reality
at some point
at some point
they're going to have to just do that
you know people these problems are way
bigger than me and way bigger than my
podcast all right i'm just gonna [ __ ]
uh
i'm just gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna just
i don't know what tap out of this so
you're actually telling me so 90 of the
[ __ ] isn't
recyclable so what i'm actually doing is
contributing
to the pollution that's going to last
for anywhere from 800 to 1000 years is
how long it takes for plastic to break
down
i'm going to make the world a worse
place while simultaneously
helping to finance
some [ __ ] eyes wide shut party for
some [ __ ] that owns that company
who's gonna give himself uh a uh you
know a 500 million dollar bonus one day
yeah you know what this is why you know
i kind of just tapped out all that
federal reserve [ __ ] because it's just
so overwhelming
so depressing and then when you try to
talk it to reg to regular people about
it they always turn it into a political
or a religious issue and they just start
screaming and yelling about the standing
president or the last president
you know if you're a liberal right now
you're still blaming trump if you're
[ __ ] a a
[ __ ] red thai person you think
everything's
biden's fault
and it's just it's just
yeah that's why once again
i'm in a house in the middle of nowhere
sitting on a porch by myself staring
into the woods
doing my part for the earth
killing myself um all right baby shark
bites man's finger off i saw this video
i saw this video and the level of
empathy that i have for this guy
because we've all in our own way lived
this guy's story we just want to rewind
the previous minute of your life but
you've done irreparable damage
this [ __ ] guy right he said hey billy
bear you're always talking about how you
don't like the ocean because sharks are
out there i found this video on
instagram of a dude losing his pinky
finger to a baby tiger shark check out
the barrel roll on the sh shark did to
yank the thing off i saw it
for whatever reason this guy is trying
to pick this [ __ ] thing up
it it did like one of those jiu jitsu
roles
you know where they
skip the hip it's like this it's no good
like this ah it's good that's all i
remember from my jujitsu classes i took
in the late 90s
i remember i was just getting the [ __ ]
kicked out of me and i was like i'm
trying to book a pilot out here what the
[ __ ] i'm what am i
am i trying to join the delta force what
am i doing so i stopped taking it and i
never booked a pilot
[Laughter]
he lost on both fronts everybody whoo
yeah so it did like this jujitsu roll
and just [ __ ] grabbed the guy's pinky
finger
spun around and the guy he handled it
like a champ he goes ah [ __ ] i just lost
my goddamn pinky
i'm [ __ ] believable
just like that
lost a [ __ ] digit now i gotta say if
you're gonna lose any of them
that's a good one
all right unless you're trying to throw
a change up then i think you're [ __ ]
no it's got to be one of the pitches
you know
i always thought if you had like your
hand all your fingers on on the ball the
elements weren't curled down
it's not as effective but you can move
your arm really fast isn't that what a
changeup is like the arm motion is the
same the same speed
bill how much more [ __ ] that you don't
really know about you're going to talk
about i don't know um yeah that's like
um
that's just one of those moments you
know
like it's one of those moments why i
never fully enjoyed shop class like i
loved
you know metal class and i loved the
woodworking class and all of that but
there there was just something
uh about
uh the band saw
you know what i mean and the [ __ ]
shop guy would always tell you stories
about people who got their fingers cut
off and how i picked it up in the
sawdust when it got spit out the other
side they reattached it and he has
massive nerve damage all of this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um
yeah i try to stay away from that try to
stay away from power tools and sharks
the ocean in general
um you ever think
that the ocean is the solution to us
it's just gonna kind of rise up and just
wash it all away
and then the next fish will actually be
like immune
to plastic
be something that they kind of thrive on
be like their little oceanic latte uh
hey i used to think that a long time ago
that the ocean water was the toxic waste
left over from the last people
that [ __ ] the planet up
and they were just washed away and
there's no evidence of them and millions
of years goes by and it all just [ __ ]
disappears and then we come out of the
toxic waste
like you know they'll be like plastic
people next
hey do you think when the robots come
that they'll solve all these problems
or do you think that they'll be racist
against like [ __ ] older models
you know that that that's that's like
the status thing
um
that you're a newer robot therefore
you're better than the other robots
because we're gonna that's the worst
thing because they're trying to create
them
to have like human feelings and this
just all comes down to so many guys
don't know how to get [ __ ]
i swear to god that's all it is and it'd
be like wouldn't it be great
if i could just program a woman to [ __ ]
me
but i don't want it to be all [ __ ]
robotic i wanted to be act like a real
woman
it acts exactly like a real woman except
it says yes when i ask it if i can [ __ ]
it right
and then it's gonna have it's gonna have
jealousy envy insecurity racial issues
and all of that [ __ ] and uh that'll be
funny right when the robots kill us off
and then
we are superior and then they slowly
kill themselves off
how would they slowly kill themselves
off depends on what they need
they need energy
um
just like we do right they're in the
same [ __ ] boat they just eat
different [ __ ]
you know out of all the podcasts i've
done well i've just been talking about
[ __ ] i have no idea what i'm talking
about this this one is is right up there
we got robotics
world history
uh
home security um
all right new gold standard
hey billy ginger privileged burr
my name is ryan and i'm from
saskatchewan canada
i love it up there man i had a good time
in in saskatoon
and uh regina
uh one of the great north's flyover
provinces
last monday you were explaining how the
world has i was not i'm never explaining
okay i am i am just riffing and i and i
don't know what i'm talking about uh how
the world has moved away from the gold
standard to a completely baseless ponzi
scheme economy well i am one of those
many people who i'm one of many people
who believe that in
the not too distant future water is
going to become the new gold yeah i know
that's why [ __ ]
george debbie
after you know he helped [ __ ] create
a never-ending war that bankrupted our
country is out there now what's he doing
next to the people he's buying up land
in south america that [ __ ] sits on an
aquifer that's what i heard do i sound
like one of those conspiracy theory
[ __ ] podcasts this week
i have no
information on that whatsoever other
than the fact that somebody told me
that's what he's doing i've never even
looked it up
um all right which despite our best
efforts is going to bring canada front
and center in the mind's eye of the
world i believe that we're sitting on
approximately 20 of the world's fresh
water and we aren't even tapping into
most of it yet
yeah so you guys are gonna be wide open
to get invaded so you better you better
get off your [ __ ] horsies with your
red jackets
all right and come up with something
here i really hope i live to see the day
your special forces is gonna come from
thunder bay is what i'm guessing i
really hope i live to see the day when
our news media is able to try to scare
us by blasting images of a caravan of
dry mouth maga hat
wearing hillbillies coming from for the
border
fear-mongering talking heads screaming
at the television
uh you know they're just going to waste
it making sweet tea and kool-aid
can't wait uh but anyway i hope to catch
you live someday really enjoy what you
do and as always go [ __ ] yourself yeah i
think that type of [ __ ] we got to get
away from that we got to stop making fun
of people that are into trump and
you know and whatever the [ __ ] they're
saying about people that are into biden
it's really just ripping us all apart
it's unfortunate
what are you gonna do um
it is what it is and i take great
comfort knowing that i can only die once
all right there we go
underrated reruns
i watch the same shows over and over
again uh when people suggest a new show
it sucks
one out of ten times
one out of ten
don't you be nine out of ten one out of
ten times okay one i'd rather enjoy
seinfeld or cheers than try and get into
an eight part mini-series about some
[ __ ] who started a company
they take liberties
and you're you're better off watching a
documentary anyway anyways he actually
wrote the sentence they take liberties
and you're better of watching a
documentary anyways how i say it the
people who flip out about the flavor of
the week shows are like seagulls at the
beach just eating whatever is in front
of them
don't call me old and disgruntled i'm 34
what shows do you re-watch
that's a great question i also i've
tapped out of most new shows
although my wife watched one the other
night that looked cool about this chef
who has a recurring nightmare about a
bear
um
and i was just
you know just the way it shot and just
going oh my god how much [ __ ] time
did that take and the acting is
incredible
um not to mention the lead
sort of looks like an amalgam of sean
penn and sylvester stallone two of my
favorite movie stars of all time so i'm
all in
uh
what shows do i rewatch i actually go
back and i rewatch
[ __ ] that i never that i missed
when i was younger because i was before
my you know it came on after my bedtime
so
i've watched everything from uh the
untouchables peter gunn
77 sunset strip
i watched a bunch of atom12s and
emergencies
i watched those when i was a kid but
most time i was told i had to go to bed
what i really wish would come back if i
could find it
was the six million dollar man
um
i've said for years one of the great
episodes
up into that moment in time was when the
six million dollar man fought the seven
million dollar man which really fits
into what i was talking about in the
future where robots are going to be
racist i cost more money i'm better than
you right
and i just remember he [ __ ]
he punched the guy's face off
and it was funny too when the face came
off it was it just looked cause like his
face moved i was obviously a real actor
so it was all like
you know you can just grab somebody's
face and oh you know grab their cheek
look at joe right
when the [ __ ] thing landed it was
clearly just like plastic
and then behind him was like you know
just like the eyeballs and all these
wires and [ __ ]
and i was making all this
[Music]
crazy [ __ ] that was i mean it was like
that was graphic for what the [ __ ] you
saw there was no internet
and then the seven million dollar man
came running at him and the genius of it
was because they were supposed to be
super fast
that they filmed it in slow motion so
you bought everything
and uh
lee mages
picked up like a [ __ ] steel girder or
a pipe that just happened to be laying
there and it's a seven million dollar
man
came at him he just [ __ ] impaled him
on it
there's the one where he fought bigfoot
played by the late great andre the giant
i mean just all [ __ ] like that is stuff
that i i would go back and re-watch but
then there's the other one i i'm really
partial to
all of those shows that are like uh
cops and gum shoes private investigators
there was a million of them
like you know telly savalas robert urich
i i liked all of those um
you know all of those shows procedural
shows were great back then too
they weren't so [ __ ] serious
you know
it's just like a bunch of guys just
sitting around giving each other [ __ ]
then they'd go out and they'd [ __ ]
kill people every episode
like i remember ephraim zimbalist jr the
amount of time or peter gunn peter gunn
in particular the amount of times that
he walked into a room and someone was
behind the door and smacked him on the
head and knocked him out
the guy was just out [ __ ] cold every
single [ __ ] episode
um
you know
i mean it just it should've you know he
probably was one of the first
i already talked about this [ __ ] you
know those are the shows that i watch i
would like to watch when i get a little
more free time once i get on the other
side of this movie i would like to watch
some kojaks
and um
and then just i like i like the ones
from the 60s because i like the early
70s because i liked the cars and i just
loved like
what a big deal
that
the hero of of the of the show like the
car that they drove
was so [ __ ] important and they had to
have like a badass car even if they had
like a four-door sedan like steve
mcgarrett
played by the great late great jack lord
on hawaii 5-0
i forget what he had i'm bad with the
chrysler stuff he had some sort of
chrysler
um it was a four-door
in like the first year of it too because
they kept updating it but you know
remember evelyn symbolist jr i think he
kept he kept driving thunderbirds
throughout 77 sunset strip and it was
like a big [ __ ] deal
you know like i love the fall guy lee
majors again when he had that chevy
silverado that black and gold one was
the [ __ ]
all right jack
lord
car
hawaii 5-0 let's see what did he drive
he drove a mercury oh my fault it was a
lincoln ford mercury
a mercury marquee
brome he had a 74.
let's see here
that was such a sweet [ __ ] car
oh do they have the actual one how the
[ __ ] do you prove that that's the actual
one
really blows my mind how that [ __ ] works
um yeah i was like more into that type
of [ __ ] but uh
i'd say if i had to go back and just
watch [ __ ] from my childhood i would
watch welcome back carter
i would watch wkrp in cincinnati
um
barney miller
fish the spinoff
the jeffersons
all in the family sanford and sun
i mean sanford and son is just to this
day just the writing on that was just
[ __ ] unbelievable
um
oh my god my eyes are going i just saw a
thing i thought it said led zeppelin
attacked at new york event
and actually said representative lee
lee zeldin
i thought lee zeldin said led zeppelin
that's that's not too far off is it
um
opinion is joe biden sinking
oh jesus christ i i yeah i would say you
know i wouldn't anybody who's going to
be president right now is going to
[ __ ] sink
you stick 20 trillion dollars into the
[ __ ] economy
um no it's not it's because he's got a
blue tie i know it isn't if trump was in
there be even worse
ah jesus christ um
all right anyway with that that is the
podcast for this week i'm still watching
the red sox i'm still gonna hang in
there i love the dog days of summer
and um i want to thank everybody in
montreal that's going to come out to my
show you're going to get a freaking
[ __ ] great show i can tell you that
right now this is certain times you know
sometimes i wonder other times i know
this time i know
it's going to be uh
oh it's gonna be a great time and uh i
don't know i'll get to you know try out
my french when i'm up there in french
canada even though that they have they
have more a different accent up there
i'll see how it works um so that's it
everybody go [ __ ] yourselves and i will
check in on you on thursday alrighty
okay thank you very much
you